so i might not be at home in my studio
but that doesn't mean you guys aren't
getting iphone
content the keynote just officially
ended it was incredible apple
just really does not disappoint when it
comes to doing these virtual keynotes
they really are setting the bar for how
to do an amazing event
and this one was no exception the
transitions from the homepod to the
iphone to everything like it was
so beautifully shot so congratulations
apple on another amazing event
we have seen so many leaks so many
rumors over the course of the past year
but now today it's official it's here
and we're gonna talk about it right now
so basically
every single iphone as we had imagined
all has 5g
now verizon was one of the leading
partners today on stage and they
announced they are turning on
5g nationwide to 1800 cities which would
mean they're giving access to 200
million people
and this is all coming alongside of the
launch of the new iphone 12. here
is the current lineup of phones
available right now so we have an iphone
se
that's available for 3.99 iphone 10r for
4.99
the iphone 11 available for 5.99 the
iphone 12
6.99 and iphone 12 pro starting at 9.99
so that's our entire current 2020 iphone
lineup let's get in
to what's new so the first thing they
talked about was the new iphone 12
and an iphone 12 mini this was such a
huge rumor like are they gonna do a mini
are they not gonna do a mini they kind
of glossed over the fact that there was
a mini iphone
but i feel like they kind of did this
because basically the iphone 12 and the
iphone 12 mini
have the same exact specs and i think
this is really great because
if you do want to get a smaller phone
you're not going to have to skip out on
any type of specs or any camera settings
you will have the same exact phone as
the 12 just in a smaller version
or a larger version so both of the 12s
have a new aluminum design with a new
super retina xdr oled display
with a new ceramic shield that is
tougher than any current smartphone
glass
they said that this is actually four
times more durable so if you do drop it
it's four times stronger than the
previous glass that they had on their
phones
and of course if you know me i drop my
phone quite often and i
i must say i haven't shattered an iphone
in quite
a long time and i still drop my phone
quite consistently so the fact that this
is going to be a much stronger glass you
guys know that i am
so here for it i love taking photos and
videos and the 12 has a new advanced
dual camera system with an ultra wide
and wide angle camera
it's also super cool that night mode and
deep fusion is now available on all
cameras both of the 12s have an a14
bionic chip which is up to 40
faster than the a13 50 faster graphics a
6 core cpu
4 core gpu all while being 11 thinner 15
smaller in volume
and 16 lighter it also now has
16 neural neural i can never say that
word
i say it wrong every single time we
dramatically increased the performance
of our neural engines
16 of them they've been doubled the
previous were eight
all that not being said this is allowing
for a huge performance boost
there's like several words in my
vocabulary that for the life of me
i just can't pronounce i always love the
new colors and the 12 comes in five
different colors there's a blue
a green a black a white and a product
red i actually really like this product
red color
it looks like it's a little bit lighter
of a color it's kind of hard to tell
looking just at the images so i'm sure
maybe in person it might look different
pre-orders for the 12 begin october 16th
and shipping october 23rd and the 12
mini pre-orders will begin
november 6th and shipping november 13th
guys that's so soon
i'm really excited to see more of the
mini because we kind of didn't really
see much of it in the keynote so i kind
of really want to see that side by side
in comparison to the iphone pro max
because it's such a small tiny little
device
i can't wait to see it in person let me
know in the comments below what your
favorite iphone 12 color is
it's no secret that i'm a huge fan of
video and shooting videos on my iphone
is obviously something that i do quite
often so
this is really huge i know a lot of
people might not understand
how incredible this is the iphone 12 is
the first camera to be able to shoot
dolby vision hdr video not only will it
be able to shoot it but you can edit
view and share these cinemagrade videos
right from your iphone you will be able
to shoot the dolby vision hdr videos
on both the iphone 12 and the iphone 12
pro max but the big difference
is you will only be able to shoot 30
frames a second on the iphone 12
whereas the pro upgrade you'll be able
to shoot 60 frames a second
the fact that you're able to do this
across all of the iphone 12 models
is really really exciting they also have
a new updated and improved cinematic
video stabilization
you can also do night mode time lapses
with a tripod
and you can even have longer handheld
night mode photos because of this
increased stabilization and even now do
night mode on the front-facing camera
this was also really cool they kind of
quickly went through it but there's a
new thing called magsafe the iphone 12
and iphone 12 pro max now have magnets
built into the back of it
so this is going to help with increased
accuracy when trying to charge your
phone apple's coming out with some cool
magnetic
chargers which will basically snap right
onto the back of your phone
and give it a faster wireless charge
they also have some magnets built into
the new iphone 12 cases
so that magnet will connect to the
magnet on the phone and then it'll
connect to the accessory
and then it'll do pass through charging
and they even have some really cool
accessories they showed like this little
folio pouch but this is kind of leading
into a really cool development for
third-party accessories so i can only
imagine
how many amazing mounts or like really
cool things that people are gonna do
with this new magnetic oh my god i can
put it on my refrigerator i don't know
why that's my first thought but i feel
like that's just what people do with
magnets so pretty much everything that
we just talked about
is all in the lower end iphone 12 model
so everything that was announced today
in the iphone 12 is also available in
the 12 pro and pro max
the 12 pro max has a stainless steel
band and a precision milled
back glass and also has the new front
ceramic shield it comes in four
different colors
silver graphite gold and the pacific
blue that we've been seeing
for the past few months so this gold is
definitely a little more
on the actual gold like a yellow gold
the outside stainless steel band is
really shiny and i'm trying to decide
which color to get because i do have the
new graphite watch
and do i want my iphone to match my
watch am i ever going to actually see it
because i'm probably going to put a case
on it
and i really love having the white case
with the white
camera showing through help what do i do
i'm going to put a poll up here so you
guys can help me decide which phone i
should get you can also leave me a
comment below and let me know what your
favorite iphone 12 pro color is
so the pro display went from a 5.8 inch
to a 6.1
inch and the pro max went from a 6.5 to
a 6.7 inch display this is the same a14
bionic chip that is in the iphone 12
so we did go over some of those specs
previously i cannot wait to try out
these cameras it has a new seven
element lens wide camera with an f 1.6
aperture
which is the fastest ever on an iphone
this will give you 27
improved low light performance in photo
and video the ultra wide camera has 120
degree field of view
and a 52 millimeter telephoto camera
bringing an optical zoom range of up to
four times
look who's here maddie hi now in the pro
max it has a brand new telephoto with a
65 millimeter focal length this is up
from 52 which is allowing for longer
framing for portraits
and you can optically zoom in 2x for an
even closer shot the wide angle also has
the new seven element lens with a larger
pixel sensor and a new sensor shift
technology to improve image
stabilization
the entire sensor is actually stabilized
as opposed to just the lens
so this will make a huge improvement in
both photo and video stabilization
i had so much fun messing around with
the lidar and the new ipad pro so they
are basically bringing that lidar sensor
now to the iphone 12 pro this is also
going to assist with six times faster
autofocus in video
and photos along with improvements in
night mode for depth sensing
dolby vision hdr is such a huge addition
to the iphone pro camera system
and i really cannot wait to try this out
we'll be able to shoot in 10 bit giving
access to
700 million colors which is 60 times
more than before again this is so
exciting because this isn't just
available on the pro models this is
available
on all of the iphone 12s so just to
reiterate this is the first time ever
that a device can not only shoot
but be able to edit color grade view and
be able to share this dolby vision
hdr content you will be able to airplay
dolby vision hdr content to a tv that
does support it but if you do have a tv
that doesn't
or some other device the iphone will
automatically detect what it's being
sent to
and send the highest quality version of
whatever that piece of content is
to your tv or device free orders for the
12 pro begin
october 16th and shipping the 23rd the
12 pro max will pre-order november 6th
and ships
the 13th which one are you guys gonna
get are you gonna get one are you not
gonna get one why why not oh something
else that they mentioned the keynote
which
was really awesome is the fact that
league of legends is now coming to the
iphone
league of legends wild rift will be
available and they showed some gameplay
during the keynote i think it's amazing
what league of legends has done for
esports because they really did kind of
bring this to mainstream media
showing people that video games yes they
are games but this can be taken
seriously this can be turned into an
entire esports community and what's
really cool about league of legends is a
lot of times they have really incredible
commentators so when you're watching
matches
even if you don't play the game you're
still able to understand and grasp
what's happening anyway i'm super
excited to try that out when that is out
for iphone
so be sure to look for some content on
that very soon i'm definitely really
excited about the future of 5g
but it definitely does still feel a
little bit early
thankfully with apple now officially
jumping on board it'll be more appealing
to the masses
even though apple might not have been
the first to 5g i feel like in typical
apple fashion they might not be
completely last to the party but when
they do show up at the party
they usually have the best gift and it's
probably
gift wrapped just perfectly and
basically what i'm saying
is now that apple has 5g i think it's
officially here
fergie just got real one thing though
that i am
a little bit sad about i think you
probably know
is the fact that there is no usbc
charging in
any of the iphone 12s they are including
a
usbc charger to lightning but they're
also not including charging bricks
in any of the boxes for any of the
phones and they're also making the boxes
much slimmer
there was a couple people on twitter
that were saying so now that you're
including
a usbc charger all of the bricks that
you previously have
in your iphones were all the type a
so now that they're usb-c where do we
but that brings me back to the fact that
with this new magnetic wireless charging
wireless charging is going to become so
much more of a norm so instead of buying
that extra brick for your usbc charger
you probably would just get this
wireless charger and start wirelessly
charging your phone more often than
plugging it in
and i said this before in one of my
rumor videos i pretty much mostly
wirelessly charged for the past couple
of years so really plugging my phone in
has not really been a thing anymore and
the other thing that i was very
sad about is the fact that they don't
have touch id
in any of the phones i thought maybe
since they did bring it to the ipad air
on the power button
that there was like a really small
chance they might have been able to
sneak it in here
in the iphone 12 pro at least i guess i
kind of feel like they've been working
on this phone
long before the pandemic struck so the
need for touch id right now has become
basically critical i have no plans to
stop wearing a mask
anytime soon in public places even after
this all passes
so i think for me really kind of having
that touch id would have been really
incredible
and not just for me i think for everyone
because
i think masks should be here to stay in
the long run if you are around people
i think just honestly our health is so
important
we could stop the spread of a lot of
different types of viruses but even
things like the flu or the cold ah
i don't know i think i've turned into a
germaphobe anyway i think that
everything that we sort of expected was
announced today as far as iphones were
concerned
i know there were a lot of rumors
running around about things like air
tags or airpods studio
and maybe some sort of a mention of
apple silicon but
we didn't get that but that's okay
because that just means that there's
probably going to be some more
announcements on the way
so i kind of feel like they might try to
sneak something in there right before
the holiday season
home depot i saw already has christmas
trees up it's not even freaking
halloween yet and you're already pushing
christmas trees
i'm not ready but what i am ready for is
the iphone and also the homepod mini
kind of excited about that i know i
didn't touch on it in this video but i
will be doing a separate video
on that talking about it they said that
the new homepod has improved siri
accuracy and then there's a really cool
thing called intercom
so basically this is kind of something
that they already have on amazon alexa
right now that intercom message
will go across basically every device
that's connected so to go through
carplay through your airpods through
your phone
through your apple watch so definitely
excited to try that out
um i think that's all i have right now
i'm super excited about this my sister
and i are also going to be recording a
podcast talking about all of the things
that were announced today
so if you guys want to check that out be
sure to subscribe on apple podcasts and
also our youtube channel
youtube.com samebrain you can also just
search for same brain on any
podcast platform or you can go to anchor
fm same brain
and that will give you a link to a bunch
of places so you can subscribe
so i guess that's it i uh again i'm
traveling i also brought home our
broadcaster so we can do our podcast
i'm currently visiting my family and i
traveled for the first time in seven
months and i'm so
happy to see them and it's really
exciting so i look forward to making
some videos for you guys if i'm not 100
on top of
posting it's because i'm with my family
thank you guys again for watching this
i'll be reading all of your comments
below and answering any questions that
you have that i might be able to answer
and if there's anything that you would
like to see me make a video about any of
the upcoming apple products
leave a comment below don't forget to
subscribe hit the bell
so you'll receive notifications when i
post a new video because tech dober is
officially here
and there's a ton of stuff that i'm
currently working on so
i'll see you guys in the next video bye